She is pretty in pink and
ready for business.
Since Mattel
launched the iconic Barbie doll in 1959,
she has captured the hearts
and imaginations of millions of people
around the world.
She's been a lawyer, she's been a doctor.
She has flown into space
and even become president.
Now
business is booming ahead of the Barbie
live action movie next week.
The Nasdaq, which joins us live now.
Things are different, though, for Barbie
compared to
when you and I were growing up.
I actually didn't even know
how old you are.
I'm guessing we're the same age. Roughly.
Yeah, roughly. More or less.
And so back in the 1980s, early nineties,
you know, everybody had a Barbie doll.
It's not the same anymore.
Is Barbie still relevant?
And how will that affect
box office numbers for the movie?
Right.
And I think that's what this movie
is designing designed to test out.
I mean, Barbie really needs
no introduction.
She's been around for 64 years.
And Mattel,
the maker of Barbie, has done
lots of brand partnerships
before clothing coloring books.
But this is the first live action movie.
And the president of Mattel
tells me
that he's hoping
that the nostalgia
of Barbie brings longtime
fans into the theater.
But also, Zane tries to go after a brand
new audience. Watch
Barbara,
Millicent Roberts,
you know her as Barbie parents.
Mattel,
born in 1959,
but doesn't look a day over 19.
Everyone had a Barbie
and it was a big thing
to have about next week.
Barbie comes to life
in a new movie with an A-list director
and actors. Hi, Barbie.
Hi, Ken.
Distributed by CNN's parent company,
Warner Brothers Discovery.
It's an incredibly important milestone
for the brand.
Barbie, beloved
by girls and boys around
the world, has had ups and downs.
Back in 20 1450 and we hit a low
and it was a moment to reflect
in the context of why
why did Barbie lose relevance.
She didn't reflect the physicality
the look if you will, of the world
around us.
Now, Barbie,
Ken and friends have many different
skin tones, shapes and special traits
that make them look more like us.
But this year's first quarter
sales at Mattel
slumped down 22% from last year.
How is
Mattel and Barbie viewed as a brand
There's been a lot of decline
and that differentiation
and that relevance
that keep her brand
fresh and top of mind
from a purchase perspective.
And when that happens, brands
go into a place of fatigue.
Mattel hopes
this new movie will give them the boost
they're looking for.
We also now have the opportunity to reach
new ages and stages
that ultimately
from a business perspective,
provides huge merchandizing
and monetization opportunities.
We're standing in front of Barbie
at home,
mom toys owner Eileen Geyer
can't keep movie Barbie on the shelf.
Within a day, they were gone.
Have you always had Barbie and
friends in stores so lutely?
It's a staple.
It's the moms and dads
who are more nostalgic than the kids.
But that nostalgia isn't for everyone.
I don't know how she's evolved like
the ship.
A college degree now should be.
The movie has calculated for that
and people
for a reason to like five years old.
And for others,
you're never too old for Barbie.
I am 90 years old, or I should say
90 years
Young
Carol Spencer didn't
grow up playing with Barbies.
This was my first project.
But Barbie wouldn't be well Barbie
without her.
I was a designer for the Barbie doll.
Starting in 1963
for over 35 years.
And I loved every minute of it.
While Carol helped make Barbie,
Barbie helped make Mattel.
As other toys have come and gone,
Barbie is still strutting.
Barbie really carried Mattel
for a great many years.
I thought of every child
who played
with the Barbie doll as my child.
So let me tell you, I have a big family
and I love it.
And that is the magic and power of Barbie
And when Barbie launched in
1959, her job was to be a teen
fashion model.
She then evolved into a fashion designer
And then consumers started
asking questions.
Could Barbie be more than that?
Not that those careers are bad,
but they wanted to see her
in more MALE-DOMINATED fields.
So we had lawyer Barbie,
we had scientists
Barbie, astronaut Barbie, as you said.
And then, of course, here we are.
Reporter Barbie came into the microphone
and everything, and we have camera.
Woman Barbie, Bobby, low order Barbie.
And speaking of fashion,
I love that
you wore pink for this interview.
Very own brand, vanessa.
That's the OC image. Thank you so much.